e
9 o' so we'll open the regular meeting
of the ledes performance audit and
oright committee we do have a quorum
thank you all very much it's good to see
you all in fact we have I think
everyone great to see you um first order
of business is the minutes
of no I move we adopt the minutes of
March 18th as written and present so
okay motion by Senator Lang second by
representative Griffin any corrections
or
comments on the
minutes ready for vote all in favor of
acceptance please say I I I any
oppose okay the minutes are adopted
thank you very much second order of
business is
um an update on the status of our
ongoing performance Audits and
welcome good morning Madame chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Christine Young director of
audits for the LBA and with me this
morning is Jay Henry performance audit
supervisor
we'd like to provide an update of
ongoing and pending performance audits
there's not much to report today since
we did the last update just about a
month ago uh but I'll make a few brief
comments uh starting with the New
Hampshire commission for human rights we
sent the commission a draft report on uh
April 9th we'll be meeting with the
commission next week to answer any
questions they have on the
report there's a monthly commission
meeting scheduled Ed for June 6th where
the members will discuss the draft
responses to the
report and it looks like a July fiscal
committee meeting is the earliest
possible time that we'd be able to
present the
report moving on to the state oversight
of special
education uh there are no changes to
report on this audit uh work is still in
process
here moving on to the education Freedom
accounts since last met we continued
discussions with the Department on how
best to move forward with the audit and
we will continue to have discussions
with the Department on this and as a
result we're not prepared to present the
scope statement
today and that is it
for current status any questions from
the
committee do you do you have a sense of
timing on
when you will um have more updates on
special ed or the EFA
audits special education we probably
won't have another update on that for a
while uh I think our plan at this point
is try to try and get a uh chapter of
observations over to the department and
um we're still working through that
right now uh I haven't reviewed that
work and um that should come in the next
couple months I would think well a
chapter within a month yes um so that's
for special education and um on the
education Freedom accounts um I don't
have a great estimate on when the scope
statement will be ready um how about you
Jay I I think once we get uh this
they're supposed to finish their review
of the the uh contractor uh Within a
month or so so that would give us
something to look at so I think at that
point we'll probably have a scope
statement after that great yes and you
say they are looking at the contractor
are you talking about the department of
Ed is looking at their contractor
they're doing a review and then that
summary of that review presented to you
for your analysis and yes thank
you representative
Weber just a quick technical question
when you said that a chapter of our
observations is going over uh to the um
Department what what do you mean when
you say a chapter is that a partial a
part of the entire audit so yes it is
yeah that'll be a lengthy report so
we're we're talking about um presenting
that to the department in chapters okay
um just so that we can have the process
moving along instead of giving them a
whole report at the end with okay with
really really a lot to uh to take in so
so bite-sized chunks bite-sized
chunks as I Rec call you had told us
there was going to be a thick oned with
40 or so
observations yes that's correct okay so
fiscal will have some something to
digest yes okay any other questions on
the status
great okay let's move on to suspended
table and potential oned topics I
think you
all pro yes does everybody have
this great so there's public access to
bodies of water the doorway program the
appeals process they're number of them
oplc Bureau of Jan Adult Services
contract management by
HHS Bureau of Developmental services and
the interplay of division of children
youth and families and the Bureau of
Behavioral Health I note that we got a
followup letter
from
I Education team yes
bye from um some members of house
Judiciary um in support of moving
forward on a performance on of the
different appeals
processes I know if everyone's had a
chance to look at that could you tell us
how many audits you could take on right
now right now um we could take on just
one okay um so if we could get at least
one Topic at a minimum today um a couple
would be better just so that we have
something to work off of um as we start
finishing up some of these
audits s so I'm going to go the opposite
direction I'm going to ask that we don't
do number four um I think oplc is in
Lurch we've been changing the laws so
much regarding them and if I'm not
understanding Senator per will could
answer I think we have a 90 9 page Bill
sitting in uh Edna right now again
around oplc so I think that that's such
a moving Target that we should just
leave them alone for a while until the
dust settles and and we we have a little
standard there you're close I think it's
96 page so I tried to file that bill and
it was 114 Pages at the time and all
that said we can't draft it for you so
I'm glad they got it down to down little
six yeah um
any thoughts about
other so if I can follow up on a
different so
again we've had we had this conversation
another agency about appeals and the
overall process of appeals within the
state how we deal with it whether it's a
Dees or any other agency and I'm
wondering whether there's there's a
bigger topic to be had there um I know
some of the concerns were grassed around
agencies having hearings officers within
their own agency making them dependent
upon the agency and necessarily not
likely to rule against the agency um or
at least it's probably not in their best
financial interest to do so and keep
their job possibly and so the I know
that we were having a discussion I'm
trying to remember what committee it was
in but we're having a discussion about
the bigger overarching idea of how New
Hampshire handles hearings and appeals
within agencies um and I don't know if
we want to just pick on this one agency
or whether we want to take a
bigger overarching you know big picture
view of how hearings and appeals happen
within the state within agencies and
identify what they look like
representative
Weber thank you madam chair um I think
that's a really interesting topic I
don't think that first of all I my first
thought was making any audit bigger is
probably inviting it to be less thorough
because we have limited resources and my
second thought is that uh when you're
talking about that kind of inquiry about
the appeals process that sounds to me
very much like a study committee not not
an issue for an audit and I think if
we're looking for an audit then
something that's narrowly focused is a
better choice and that's just my view of
the thing I agree with you I got it was
only going to be an inch deep and a mile
wide yeah I got
that as I see in this letter we're to
this
proposal actually looks at four
different appeals
processes to begin with the agency is
here if we want to talk to who's here
from the
oh do you guys want to come up
rearrange the deck
chair
yes yes representative Weber thank you
very much um just as a preliminary
matter um I think as as people are
addressing their comments which I'm very
interested in um am I not correct that
what the audit does is look at and I
probably should have asked this before
we change the chairs over but what the
audit does is look at whether what's
happening on the ground comports with
our statutes rather than is it a good
thing generally so I just want to be
sure that we keep that all firmly in
mind as we're going forward with the
with making determinations that's the
way I've always read performance a
good
morning good morning uh for the record
I'm Bob Scott commissioner with the
Department of Environmental Services I
have my assistant commissioner uh Adam
uh kpo uh here with us also uh if I
could uh Madam chair uh maybe it would
be helpful to explain the current status
legal status of where we are statutorily
with our uh our for councils so going
back in time to answer the senator uh
Lang's question uh well over a de decade
ago we transitioned to have not any
agency staff being the hearings officer
for these type of appeals uh we uh had
relied on uh the Attorney General's
office to appoint somebody to do that
for us uh in the last uh legislative
session in House Bill 2 uh we we sought
some further uh uh streamlining if you
will of the council process so what we
had uh asked for was multiple things uh
we asked for the quorum to that's
necessary to get a council moving on
appeals to be reduced to three that is
in place
today uh we also asked that these
councils be advisory to the hearing
officer appointed by the Attorney
General's office that did not get
through the legislation that start that
the as introduced house bill to had that
and then that was that was taken out
instead of that in place of that was put
a uh legislative study committee
requirement was put in uh which we
strongly support uh also uh we did not
we were prior to House Bill 2 last year
we were Staffing uh the appeals process
uh we kind of had a a a firewall but
with some staff uh supporting the
councils doing the getting the paperwork
for appeals and all that ready for them
I didn't like the Optics of that that
also was moved to the Attorney General's
office uh last session as well so
there's what what I'm here to say is I'm
not sure first of all there's there's no
over overlap with the Department in our
appeals process rightly so we're
separated so you know we issue our
decisions based on the record at the
time if those are
appealed that's the only action we we've
issued that that appeal not the appeal
the the permitting action which is being
appealed and then it's entirely in the
council's in the department of Justice's
hands so there's no overlay with I think
rightly so with the Department of
Environmental Services so I think
listening to Senator Lang that's that's
the direction I think you want to be for
the other other departments um so we do
have a representative from the
Department of Justice here also he's
willing to speak if need be but my I
guess what I'm here to tell you I
believe we've made changes to do exactly
I think the type of thing you want to do
we frankly uh we would like to see these
these councils move quicker also which
is why we were suggesting they become
advisory to the hearings officer so they
would be the subject matter experts the
hearing officer would be the final
decision maker uh that didn't make it
through I would I know that again House
Bill 2 had a had a legislative study
committee requirement and I believe
um held over Senate Bill 84 had the same
thing so we strongly support that I'm
not right quite sure what a audit would
do again as as rightly pointed out I
believe an audit is of are you following
the current laws and rules
but again that all just change so I'm
not quite sure what we'd be
accomplishing but uh we're here to
answer any questions you have
representer we do you know where we are
in the study committee process at this
point is that that was House Bill too so
it should have been started already I'm
gon to uh let Adam answer that but I
think nowhere is the answer hold on yeah
good morning um I we look when we looked
on the website for the hb2 study
committee it didn't look like they had
met uh or at least they didn't file a
report however I know in s sp84 which
was held over from the last session it
has the same study committee in it and I
know that P just recently passed the
house um in January and so that should
be headed to the Senate any time now and
we and like uh the commissioner said we
uh we are in strong support of a study
committee to look at this
yes thank you you answered all my
questions at least regarding your agency
uh and how you handleing appeals I like
the idea that's outside of your Agency
for the hearings offic so
thanks
um I think that what the representatives
of the Judiciary Committee were
concerned about was that all four
appeals processes are different
I
think Madam chair is there a question
for me I can address that if you like
yes pleas so so yes so right now the the
the four councils are set up by Statute
with subject matter experts depending on
the type of permit that we're doing so
there's an air counsil for uh air air
pollution control uh permits so they're
more uh aligned to to understand those
better similarly we have one for
Wetlands uh again Waste Management so
that that's by Design uh they have
synergized their rules over the years so
by and large their rules are are
essentially similar uh again that's out
of the Department's control we have a
separation so that's up to the councils
themselves not the department uh but we
certainly encourage that so so yes there
are four different councils that's again
I would argue would be fodder for maybe
a study committee uh a think we had
thrown out in the past is maybe a single
unified environmental Appeals Council
that perhaps could be advised by these
subject matter experts in that type of
thing so again I think there's a lot of
a lot of ways we can still improve the
process so and I guess um my latest
experience with the air
permit division is in my own District
there's a proposal for to build an
asphalt plant and Dees came down to
nashwa and held this very wasn't a
public hearing but it was public
information
session but the statute that they're
supposed
to base their opinion their opinion on
is a public health statute correct
and it was not clear to me that your
department interacts with HHS
on how that statute is supposed to be
interpreted M when you're evaluating an
air permit so it seems like maybe that's
the kind of thing a performance audit
could look
at potentially uh so
125c uh it is a public health statute
but explicitly says the air Resources
Division of the Department of
Environmental Services shall there
there's a a lot of that language in
there so that's where the air pollution
control regulations are are housed uh
and that's where the expertise is in the
air Resources Division that division
also has an environmental Public Health
Group also and their job is to Lia with
the uh HHS uh public health and as
you're probably aware we're in the same
building so it's pretty easy to do that
so they do that fairly frequently so
thank you other yes reper
uh thank you madam chair I just don't
understand this because I haven't been
involved with Dees but are the councils
part of Dees or part of the AG's
office uh the councils are uh sep
they're administratively attached as far
as we do have the only involvement we
have right now is we'll have secretarial
support that can help them take minutes
of hearing so not hearings excuse me but
they one of their jobs is to advise our
divisions again these are subject miter
experts from the communities uh some are
from industry some are from uh
environmental groups depending on how
the statute set up and one of their
roles is to advise us on our
administrative
rules uh and that's a process we go
through to get help get a little bit
more uh context as we we go through a Ru
making process so the that's the largest
involvement we have so we'll have staff
appear before them present rules and uh
we'll have somebody help them with notes
W with minutes but when it comes to an
appeal they are totally separate we have
no involvement with them
whatsoever follow Madam CH yes so where
do they come from how the how the
councils come to be uh they're nominated
for the governor and councel process uh
in and and then reappointed uh as their
terms come
up follow on that this might be a better
question for the Auditors I'll just ask
you so this seems to imply that a lot of
the issues with the councils you must
have seen the letter from the correct
committee do I understand that
correctly that that
the the the the concern of the committee
seems to be with regard to the councils
and their decision- making I believe so
but as I was pointing out though we'
we've tried to streamline the law to
help answer some of those questions no I
get that so my question so my question
is is is it your opinion that they
really don't fall under the offices of
the Department of enery Environmental
Services Environmental Services me and
thus wouldn't even come under the audit
the correct if Auditors were coming to
ask us about it we'd say we've issued a
permit and okay thank
you yes and so again but I think to to
to your point Keith representative was
um the uh audit is about the council
right not about the agency at least
that's what representative uh Lynn is
asking and and the committee seems to be
is like the auditing the four councils
and their probably their ad proceedings
relative to appeals is what they're
looking to do at least as I read this
may I respond Madam chair yes and again
this probably needs to be opposed to the
Auditors but the question is do they
even come under our
legislator auditor ability to do that
auditing let's ask C
AG come
on would you like me to stay up also
sure okay
good morning Madam chair for the record
my name is Mark Delano I'm an Assistant
Attorney General from the Department of
Justice in the civil law
Bureau so reer would you like to ask
that
question so my question is um we've had
discussions in the past over what the
boundaries are of the LPA the Auditors
basically the per performance Auditors
do they do those boundaries include
auditing the councils which it seems
like maybe a significant part of what is
being asked of us here I would have to
take a look at the statute the govern's
audits I didn't do that in preparation
for today's meeting I can tell you
though that each of the environmental
councils are governed by their own
statute under
210 uh for instance the wetlands council
is uh established under RSA 2
105 uh hyphen little a uh and and each
of the other other four have their own
Provisions in 210 so they fall under
from a um organizational standpoint
statutorily within the dees department
but each of those councils is only
administratively attached so the dees
doesn't have um oversight over those
different councils they are independent
ofs in that regard as your question
representative regarding uh whether or
not audit an audit could be performed to
those councils that's something that
we'd have to go back and look at the
statute on uh because and as I said I
unfortunately didn't prepare for that
question
today okay
well
um that would be good to know okay
thanks yeah okay let's representative
Weber question I'm just trying to figure
out if I'm missing something here
they're statutorily created that's
correct
and I guess if you're doing the review
my question would be could we divide it
into two parts one of which
is I can't figure out why we wouldn't be
able to audit them but perhaps you'll
let let us know but the second part is
how would we word an audit to properly
include those things that we're trying
to get at and that would be
helpful
commissioner again I'm not an attorney
so uh take take it for what you will I
know in the past when we've had uh an
audit done with the Department uh at
least in one occasion they looked at the
related Council
also
yes representative uh the trouble is is
as an attorney I I can't guess on those
sorts of things so um and that and
that's why that's why uh you know my my
uh answer may have sounded a bit evasive
but that wasn't the intention the
intention was to communicate that I
don't know the answer right now but I
will try to get it for
you Senator Pearl thank you commissioner
I'm trying to make sure I have my head
around these councils did I hear you
correctly that they only serve in an
advisory they they don't really have any
authority to make an adjudicated
decision they're just
an advisory is that correct no uh so
what I was trying to relay is uh our
initial request in the house house bill
in number H Bill 2 as introduced last
year that was the language so so we
reduced the the quorum to three to make
it a little bit more uh easier to happen
uh and and and we also had language in
there that would make them advisory
again to the subject matter experts to
the hearing officer who would make the
decision that did not make it through
the legislative process uh but but again
I that's one of the reasons why we're
encouraging
encouraging I think there's more work to
be done there legislatively and that's
why we're encouraging the study
committee if there's an appeal then they
decide the appeal and issue a ruling
correct so the hearing officer from the
Department of Justice will will rule on
uh matters of law uh and they will the
council themselves rule on on the the
facts of the the case so thank you just
trying to get my head around make sure I
had a correct but but do I understand
that what's being
suggested by the members of the
Judiciary Committee is not the initial
decision
process but
the
appeals because the these
councils issue an opinion opinion and
then the appeal is to the Superior Court
Supreme Court yes ma'am the Supreme
Court so I'm not exactly
sure
what part of the appeals
process is being recommended I thought
the appeal was to the councils correct
not the Supreme Court first correct if
if I may yeah exactly I think that's
what the senator was saying so the the
the initial appeal if if there's a
somebody's appealing one of our
permanent decisions would would go to
the council if they're grieved by that
then it would go to the Supreme Court
and I think there's been some discussion
in some of the bills that perhaps there
should be an intermediate step with the
superior court but again I would argue
that is fodder for legislative process
not whether you know I
don't my opinion if I may ma'am uh Senor
chair auditing this at this point first
of all we have a brand new law that's
been place and I think a lot of the
things raised in this these letters are
things that they would like to see
change in the law I don't know how an
audit does that but that's again
obviously the committee can do what they
will Madam shair if I could just add to
uh commissioner Scott's statement uh so
over at
doj uh because of the passage of hp2
we've started taking over the functions
of the appeals Clerk and we're working
on putting in place a permanent
full-time hearing officer uh because
some of the uh the funding that was at
Dees for dealing with that position has
been transferred to the Department of
Justice so so far we have a new appeals
clerk in place we have appointed uh
another Assistant Attorney General from
our Criminal Appeals division to work as
the uh uh interim hearing officer until
we identify a permanent hearing officer
so there have been a lot of changes over
the last six months and uh you know to I
guess reiterate what commissioner Scott
said there isn't much to audit at this
point because we're still kind of
putting these things in place one thing
I will will state though is that um the
councils to the extent that we were able
to do this have adopted procedural rules
for appeals which are more or less
uniform okay there are some numbering
differences there are some uh
idiosyncrasies among the councils but
for the most part uh this process
started two years ago
uh first it was uh Wetlands they were
the first to have the new rules then air
uh and then last fall uh waste and then
this past month uh water so they've you
know gone through they've been
extensively changed we've held public
hearings we've been to Jael car a few
times and uh you know so now those are
in place so I I I think that if if the
consideration now is an audit it kind of
seems as if well anything that would be
audited might be something under the old
system but because we have this new
system it just kind of doesn't seem
timely at this
point representative R thank you madam
chair I'm convinced that we're not ready
to move forward on this audit and I'm
ready to put forth another topic when we
finished with this one is there any
further
discussion I
agre yeah I I I don't feel like we're
ready to go on this one um we do have
some other potential ones do you want to
raise yours I do
first I'm looking at number six and
again I don't want to really dig into
the
contractors but when we do the dees
budget so much of each department goes
out to Contracting roughly 20% and since
this department is almost half of the
budget this this represents a sizable
amount that we know so little about in
the uh Health and Human Services
Department so just kind of a list of how
many contractors what the total cost is
and and perhaps how the process works so
that is there really is it competitive
or are they just looking for the same
contract the year after year uh is it
just kind of single bit bids and it just
goes through year after year to the same
contractors and do the same contractors
have several different contracts with
with the HHS I don't think this is
something where you really need to dig
very deep into who the contractors are
and what are they doing but has the same
contract that got five or six different
contracts and you know there was uh and
the receivables I'm interested in
knowing who's looking at the receivables
and you know how how complete are they I
mean some years ago going back quite a
while we had a contract that was
supposed to reduce teenage smoking and
we spent a couple million dollars year
after year to reduce teenage smoking
finally somebody looked at it and said
teenage smoking is increasing what are
we why are we paying these people a
million dollars a year or two million
whatever it was to reduce teenage
smoking
nothing seems to happen so we canceled
that contract in the budget that that
contractor probably spent all that money
putting out ads saying the state is not
doing enough to stop teenage smoking it
was it was on all the radios and I don't
know if it made TV but all the money
that they hadn't spent doing what they
said they were going to do they seem to
spend an advertising telling how evil
the state was for not following up but
anyway so ever since then I've been
wondering why don't we know more about
where the the contracts are going are
they going to several different people
are is there a real bidding process or
are the same people getting them year
after year and the same people may be
getting multiple contracts so I don't
need to dig into really the what's going
on but just kind of the process and I'm
hoping that we get more better
information on thank you
discussion representative
Weber isn't that something that could be
requested of LBA by um I mean it's
information it's not an audit and isn't
that something that could be requested
now either of the LBA either by um one
of the uh Finance committees or by
fiscal requested by
fiscal there's no need for an audit I
would Envision it being a little wider
then because you know that if the
process is is more complicated than just
saying okay you have the contract who
bid for it who where were the biders did
you choose the the lowest bidder um the
same person do it last year what were
the receivables were they satisfactory
have we really seen any progress from
this contractor that sort of thing uh I
don't think that's it's just a little
wider in my mind than what LBA would do
thank
you I mean I guess we could
certainly seek to understand why it
takes so
long to get a
contract to the executive Council I mean
because it takes five six
months
um
I I know they've
had
vacancies in the Contracting
unit
um but what's the will of
the committee do you want to discuss
some of these other ideas for yes Senate
so out of out of the eight on the list I
had two I wanted to take a look at one
was the doorways program the other one
was the interplay of DCF and the bureau
and number eight so number two and eight
for my concerns eight as you know
Senator you and I had to deal with an
issue this January through March with a
with a child that was stuck in the
emergency room for almost 60 plus stay
not receiving Services um that had a
problem so I'm interested in was there a
bottleneck I I I will say you all be DH
GCF the Department of Health and Human
help me dramat they were responsive they
just didn't have an answer to this
problem um and the kid wasn't involved
DC right and so the question is whether
there's any benefit that would have been
that particular one family's instance
with 60 days is there was it an
interplay issue between the agencies
trying to find uh between Behavioral
Services and DHHS to try to find
placement or was it um just we don't
have services and then on the other on
the doorway I'm sorry we bring number
eight
forward well wait we have questions so
on the doorway program again we're
seeing a significant amount of money
flow into the opioid and we're having
discussions now about marijuana and
potentially greasing uh more drug uh uh
related things going on within the state
and so the question is should we take a
look at our existing substance abuse
programs and see if they're they're
functional if they're working for our
citizens are they getting the services
and uh representative wier's point the
receivables are we seeing uh less
recidivism relative the people who have
gone into treatment um and with given
all the money we're spending so those
are the two I want to see talk about
move forward Senator Whitley thank you
madam chair um I I agree particular with
number eight um my concern is as we are
know continue to build our children's
mental health system that our systems
are talking to each other there's a lot
of overlap between dcyf and the Bureau
for children's Behavioral Health and I
just want to make sure that that um
those systems are consistent for example
many children are placed out of state
not by DCF but by the Bureau of uh
children's Behavioral Health and I think
there are differing levels of due
process when that happens and
notification and so um I know that we
are working towards decreasing the
amount of children who are placed out of
state I think that is critical and
should be a top priority I think we need
to look at it though you you saw the
situation in Tennessee and so the scope
would be I think starting to look at how
those out of state placements are made
and then secondary how those uh outof
home decisions are made um particularly
when it's involving the children's
Behavioral Health Bureau I think we have
sort of more information about how DCF
does
that something that is very much related
to that system integration piece is
who's paying for it um we know
that there is a very large budget folks
who are on finance know that the budget
for children's Behavioral Health is
really large and that's in part because
of residential placements it's also in
part because there are children that are
getting pushed into the Medicaid system
perhaps because they're not getting
coverage for services by their private
insurance companies and so we do know
that there is a level of um sort of
uh you know is it appropriate for the
state system to be providing so much
services for children that should be
getting coverage in the private
insurance so I very interested in that
question represent
Weber I I would just second all of that
um I really think that understanding
where where where the limits are where
the interstices are how how how the two
agencies mesh and how those decisions
are made I think they're I think there
are larger policy questions involved as
well but understanding how the process
works at the moment um and and how they
are dealt with I think would be really
helpful so I would um at any appropriate
time I would be glad to either move or
second a motion that we bring number
eight
forward uh as uh that of the two of them
that would be my first priority
certainly going
forward I'm also I'm interested in that
one but also the door ways
because um we spend
Millions on this program and we have no
idea really what we get for that I mean
they're open 8 to five Monday through
Friday I think how many clients are they
serving what is
the time between client showing up and
treatment or interaction with a
provider being maintained how many of
the interactions are with the phone line
versus the physical
place but
um I think those two are really
important
but if we want to entertain a motion i'
recognize someone Senator Langan mam
chair I'd move we move number eight in
position one and as a backup number two
second second if I second with me on
motion by Senator Lane further questions
discussion
Center web I just want to make sure you
all have enough guidance on that lad qu
on number eight because it is a big one
do you need any sort of
um sort of what we think the largest
problem is and move down from
there hello my name is Jay Henry I'm the
uh performance audit supervisor for the
LBA audit division um I think what we'll
need is just time to get in to that
topic I mean it sounds like there's two
there's a bureau in the division within
the department of of Health and Human
Services um we have to look at the the
the laws how that connects also just how
many children are are seen by both um
agencies so I think we probably need to
do more background we're going to come
back with we'd come back with a scope
statement and that's probably where we
can really fine-tune what you're
interested in what what's there um at
least that's my my sort of gut
reaction not the the the second point of
that question though while you're
dealing with the interplay the also the
question is the funding right so the
last the last question and setting in
line eight right oh the private
insurance General concern uh about
private insurance is not covering the
necessary need right that that's sort of
another issue that secondary issue that
the Senor with yeah I I see it as
actually not secondary I see it as a
part a symptom of the problem um you
know for example there is a door into
Medicaid uh eligibility door into
Medicaid we used to call Katie Becket it
and it and children enter that door
based on the severity of their you know
their symptoms and their disorder and so
there is a general sense that children
are getting pushed into Medicaid through
Katie Becket because they are not
getting what they need early on um and
that's the issue that I'm very very
concerned in the department of insurance
is doing a lot of work about thinking
through what is covered what is not
covered what should be covered so I'm
less concerned with that I'm more
concerned about you know that Acuity
that is leading kids to get into that
system and how much you're paying for
that instead of the private insurance
companies that make
sense okay so we have a motion to put
first number eight then number two into
the queue any further discussion or all
in favor say I I any
opposed
okay so um probably the next time we
meet you might have a proposed scope
statement at least for number eight
can I make a comment of course Madam
chair um are there any topics on this
list that we want to remove or is the
committee interested in keeping all of
them on the list for future
consideration well
Senator so again three and four we had a
pretty extensive discussion around three
and I think that's a moving Target right
now and probably been delayed for a
couple years and then we can come back
and look at it and see whether or not
that appeal process needs to be dealt
with and number four as I said again
moving Target I think that could be
taken off the list for a couple years
and be brought back if someone sees a
problem but we're making some dramatic
changes in both those areas I think we
could take them off the list for now
it'd be my
opinion Senator Perl
I'd also add number one to that was
public access to bodies of water I'm not
aware of any real concerns there in that
area I don't know how long that's been
on this yeah
list it came from the the prior
committee it was just a topic that
brought up and but without a complaint
we didn't know exactly what was wrong it
was just sort of more of an issue that
we've never looked at
okay so we're talking about taking off
one
three and four for now five is still in
litigation so I think probably we'd be
interested in this when that dust
settles um contract management we should
keep on
BDS
um I think it's been a while
sen mam chair I move I make a motion we
remove one three and four off the uh
pick it off the table and dispose of it
second
discussion okay if you're in favor of
removing
one
three and
four knowing that they can come
back please say I I I
opposed okay so we have one and two I
mean eight and eight and two and the
others um five six and seven five six
and seven
instead excellent thank you do we have
any other business representative or may
I just ask a question of course
regarding number six um it states at the
end there Department Personnel provided
dot dot dot is this possible to either
tell me when we will receive that and
maybe I'll have it or just resend that
information because that might be of
interest sure we can resend that yep
that was discussed at the August meeting
which I missed and um I believe Nathan
White made a presentation on that and
provided hand out with a couple of
charts so I may have it then thank you
sure thank anything else to come before
us okay so the next meeting will be when
Jay tells
us Jay has the power when Jay is ready
when Jay and
Christine are ready and um other than
that I think
we standard turn second all in favor I
thank you all very much thank you m
than
e e